Everyone wants to be someone.
We all want a title.
A status.
A distinction.
Something to give our existence meaning.
As a child, we are asked what we want to be
when we grow up.
We are given the impression that we are not
yet enough and must long for careers and titles
in order to feel whole.
And so we follow this thread, hoping it will
pull our life into meaning.
We all have something to contribute, something
to work towards, something to be passionate
about.
But in the process of turning these somethings
into goals and careers, it is important that
we maintain separation between them and our
sense of life and self-worth.
If we search for ourselves entirely through
our career goals, we will never be satisfied
with who we find, because career goals never
end.
Instead, we must remember that we are all
intrinsically worth as much as what we decide
we are worth.
Every human is an individual with value and
wonder in their spirit, and no career achievement,
or lack there of, can determine otherwise.
When we are young, we should be asked what
we want to DO when we are older, not who we
want to BE.
For who we are is who we are, with or without
career achievements.
The moments of our childhood are not worth
less than the moments of our adulthood just
because we did not yet have a career or status.
Our ability to create meaning and enjoy our
self is often the strongest as a child, and
we must remember that we can continue to carry
this with us all through life, independent
of our careers and statuses.
When we acknowledge our intrinsic value, regardless
of status, we become like a tree, grounded
and full of life.
And our career accomplishments become like
fruit growing from our limbs, providing nutrients
for
the world.
Our careers and accomplishments are certainly
major parts of our lives that we should appreciate
and take pride in, but if you neglect to embrace
your self-worth and sense of life outside
of them, you have missed
the point.